it was becoming hard for Gavin
Williamson to hold on a daily drip of
allegations today turned to resignation
in a letter he said because of an
ongoing complaints process and other
allegations made about his past conduct
which he refutes he recognizes he's
become a distraction and has therefore
decided to step back so he can comply
fully with the complaints process and
clear his name of any wrongdoing this
has all happened very quickly I mean we
haven't even had to wait for an
investigation before we've seen Gavin
Williamson resign well I think it's
right that Gavin Williamson has resigned
but he shows from his letter no signs
are taken responsibility for the
consequences of his own actions but the
serious Point here is that Rishi sunak
seems to be incapable of making strong
decisions as a prime minister
he was a Maverick Minister Gavin
Williamson has had four jobs in cabinet
in five years and it's not hard to find
Tory MPS with a view one who served in
government with him said he's a bully
and always has been another senior Tori
called him thoroughly incompetent
thoroughly pathetic and nasty piece of
work one more charitable MP and former
whip said the whole thing has been an
absolute Balderdash everyone knows what
goes on in the whips people just need to
grow up is Gavin Williamson a bully Mr
Sharps should Gavin Williamson remain in
the cabinet
but as more allegations surfaced
including claims he told the senior
civil servant to Slit their throat an
allegation he strongly rejected his
cabinet colleagues rallied I actually
served in the whips office under Gavin
Williamson and there was always this
great aura of you know do you remember
the cranus the spider the tarantula Etc
and the reality with with Cronus is he
was much touted
but he never actually was released to
bite anybody so that was how I always
saw uh Gavin as somebody had this sort
of aura or a Mystique around him but the
reality was he just generally got on
with his job was that an important part
but this former conservative who joined
labor says Gavin Williamson's Behavior
was one of the main reasons he left the
party it was quite implicit in uh in
that if I if I wasn't prepared to back
the government on something but I
actually cared quite passionately about
um that that there would be consequences
of them making it very clear that if if
I didn't back the government I I
wouldn't be getting a school for one of
the towns I would certainly describe it
as intimidatory as threatening as as
bullying
but this isn't just about Gavin
Williamson this government
will have integrity
professionalism
and accountability at every level
for a prime minister who pledged to
change the course losing a senior
minister so soon puts into question his
own judgment in his response to Gavin
Williamson where she sunak said he
understands and supports his decision to
step back it is the third top job sir
Gavin has been sacked from but Rishi
sunak's first cabinet loss Ali fought
Sky News Westminster